seems to me there's two problems one is
the leverage or too much debt problem
and the second thing is a failure of
leadership so I'm going to dress my
first question to Professor teen
accomplice as a practical matter how do
you implement the debt forgiveness on
mortgages especially when it seems like
many of those mortgages are been cut
apart to put in CDOs and no one knows
where they are number one so if you
could tell us on a practical basis how
you can do that and the second thing is
what stands in the way of that policy
being enacted so that's question for you
then for president Levin my question is
given that there's a failure of
leadership among politicians is it
possible for universities to step out in
front of the issue and take a leadership
stance people like Ken Rogoff people
like Professor the professor Columbia
and so on and try to speak above the
political fray above the failure of
leadership in Washington in a
coordinated voice and say these are the
policies that really must be done
because I fear that if we don't do that
soon we've lost three years already we
really could have those eight million
people industries with serious social
repercussions on the country so those
are the good John okay very nice
question so the housing the mortgage
market collapsed in January 2007 your
see do you know subprime mortgage market
the triple B's collapsed in January 2007
that's five years ago almost so we've
known for five years that there's going
to be a tremendous problem in housing
it's not that it happened yesterday and
haven't figured out what to do five
years have gone by that's why the
problems gotten so bad so one of the
things so then the problem is precisely
what you suggested these mortgages and
especially the subprime ones are all
securitized so the actual lenders are
different bond holders and the only
person with the right the contractual
right to write down the principle to
reduce the principal is called the
servicer and the servicers simply
haven't done it virtually not a single
loan subprime loan has been written down
the principal is written down they've
written the interest rate down and those
loans have Rida faulted you know
seventy-five percent of the Rida fault
you know within the next year so they
written down the 70 depending on how
much they wrote it down but anyway huge
numbers of the Rida fault when they
write down the interest because the guy
still owes much more so the bondholders
would like the principal written down
because they'd end up with more money
but the services won't do it okay so
what I and I'll explain why in a second
but I propose the practical solution I
proposed three and a half years ago
almost with a form of law student here
named Susan cognac the professor would
be you we propose that the government go
out and hire a bunch of local bankers
like a few of them in New Haven all the
subprime loans in new haven would be
sent to these local bankers and they
would have the job of modifying the loan
in a way which would make the most money
for the lender not to help the borough
are the most money for the lender and
probably that would be writing down the
principal and so that and so they would
take the decision power away from the
servicer and put it in the hands of a
banker whose job was to make money and
then you have to give incentives to
these bankers to do well you have to
compare one guy's performance against
them other guys performance so why
haven't the services written down the
loan themselves if they cut the
principal in half they cut their fee in
half if the if the if they have to
figure the most important reasons you
have to figure out how far to write the
loan down you have to know what the
house is worth now you have to get an
appraisal you have to go look at the
house you have to talk to the guy see if
you can pay the reduced you know the
reduced amount that means hiring staff
they don't own the loans they don't get
any money themselves for having done all
that work it's just a big expense to
them they don't want to go to the
expense maybe somebody will sue them if
they write down the principal so and
worst of all they own the second loans
so if you write down the first loan will
be tremendous pressure to write down the
second
and they don't want to like that 20
which they probably have to do if people
got my habit of writing down the first
loans they want to keep their second
loans and hope they get paid so if they
write down the interest on the first law
maybe the guy will pay the second law
for a while too so the services don't
have an incentive to write down the
loans the banks alone directly don't
want to recognize the losses right away
and because of that it's not happening
even if it would be into their economic
advantage so three years ago would have
been a tremendous economic advantage now
the guy people been in their houses for
two years without paying they've already
ruined some of the houses so the
advantage of writing down the principal
has partly been squandered but still
it's a good thing to do it would have
been a great thing to do three years ago
suggest your your question you know I
think the question is can't be how can
the university's take leadership on this
i mean it's its individual economists i
mean we we're up and take a position
first of all you can hear that we don't
agree on every little detail even
amongst ourselves but but i do think
that many responsible members the
economics profession have been
addressing this issue and publishing in
popular organs as well as technical work
i mean bob has written frequent columns
john has written columns ken rogoff
writes all the time a Paul Krugman maybe
a little shrill in the way he expresses
things but actually he agrees with an
awful lot of what's been said here on
this panel tonight Martin wolf writes
for the financial times you know twice a
week I mean almost always on point so
there are intelligent voices out there
in the public domain it's so what your
plaintive cry is how do we make them
hurt or how do i how do we get the
politicians to actually listen that's
the hard over here I thought it was
great professor Jacobs you focused on
leverage and you know in an aspect of
this is that you know we had this big
bubble and and to have a bubble you need
to have easy money right and where does
it easy money come from a lot of it
comes from China so a great great move
that Yale has made reason i think is to
bring stephen roche here and there's
been this sort of through the press a
little but not lately but Stephen Roche
and Paul Krugman have sort of gone at
each other a little bit about China and
so I'd like to put you on the spot here
use six economist and say there's this
question right now I think if I'm not if
I'm correct as a bill in the Senate to
put tariffs on China and Paul Krugman I
think would say that you know that's
it's good because they've been
manipulating their currency whereas
Stephen Roche says don't blame the
Chinese the problem is that Americans
don't safe enough and so I was wondering
you know where you come down on that and
for all of you should we put this should
we put tariffs you know should we put
the chair up on China and you can maybe
speak more broadly to the question of
the role of the US as the world the
dollars the world's reserve currency and
these these kind of things go ahead well
I am a little bit in the steve roach
camp there that blaming all our troubles
on the chinese i think is a little bit
too much and you know the just because
they were willing to lend that low
interest rates doesn't mean that we had
to you know we had to borrow with no
money down the Chinese have understood
leverage by the way the Chinese are
constantly managing their leverage
whenever things go you know things get
overheated they're worried about
inflation they suddenly changed the
leverage and they say people have to put
more money down Israel and housing
prices went up too high the central bank
said you have to click sixty percent
down to buy a house so the Chinese
understand leverage we don't seem to
quite get it yet as for whether the
Chinese caused our problem I I don't
think they caused a whole leverage
problem but I do think that here i agree
with Krugman that you know their policy
is to export as much as possible and
keep their their exchange rate low and
of course that gives us tremendous
numbers of goods that are practice you
know there are so cheap I think this 99
percent might get more upset when they
start having to pay twice as much for a
sweater or something like that so it's
going to be a double-edged koopmans
recommend
to make it more difficult for China to
sell here because I think it's going to
be a disaster if if the blaming of China
and economic policy directed at China
will take place in this country and in
addition remind you of what happened in
Great Depression with all kinds of
tariffs and the shutting down of
international trade I think now it's
even more more dangerous but the world
is very globalized and the Chinese
called hold the purse and owned a lot of
the a lot of the debt on this country
and blaming China will lead and one
thing is certainly inflation is there's
a certain is a big problem in some
people argue that part of the reason why
inflation was slow in the ass is the
competition and there is the impact of
the Chinese goods and all kinds of other
bad things can can sort of happen just a
word on that so the natural instinct of
an economist when you see someone
wanting to put a protectionist measure
on is to say it's wrong and it's
economically ill-advised but if the
person who did it is Paul Krugman then
you actually have to sit back and try to
understand what he's saying now not
because you want to Nobel Prize
international economics but because he
has a yield degree in economics so the
point he's making is that in a situation
where now particularly where we have
this this zero interest rate and a deep
recession that if China actually is
keeping its exchange rate up by
intervention then that is lowering us
output and US employment and I think
that's in this kind of situation is
analytically correct now the people
who've looked at that say that his
numbers are exaggerated
and it's not two or three million jobs
but quite a bit less than that but I
think on this I I think we have to to
say okay is this is this really a good
idea first place it's a precedent for
people to take these kind of beggar thy
neighbor of policies in the middle of
recessions which is a bad idea it
overlooks the possibility of retaliation
it overlooks the fact that people can do
this to us and save the way same where
we can do it to them it overlooks the
fact that for 60 years we've been really
in the vanguard of trying to promote a
free and open trading system and it's
going in the wrong direction so the
president has not been very clear on
this the Republicans have been very
clear and the Democrats have been very
clear on the wrong side and I think we
would pick the wrong side I think it's a
even though it might create a few jobs
it's not the right way to create jobs
and it's a very very bad measure and
just one footnote to that actually I
profession or house said it's
analytically correct it is in a in an
account in a model with two economies
but in a model with many economies it's
not necessarily that correct in terms of
magnitude because if you did put a 27
and a half or thirty two percent tariffs
on Chinese goods it's not clear we're
going to substitute American goods for
the Chinese production we might buy the
goods in Thailand or India or some other
country and still import them and you
wouldn't see a big impact on job on job
creation in this country okay well I
think we're on this side all right it
seems to me that this protest movement
is it's been called unfocused but it's
exactly the opposite it's perfectly well
focused on jobs and redistribution and
every one more or less agrees about jobs
and the creation of jobs everyone here
everyone on the Republican side who may
be here to agrees that there need to be
job creation and it seems to me that the
problem is that in five years of looking
at the obvious or four years the policy
prescriptions can't get it done giving
corporations huge cash infusions in
various forms doesn't get it done we
have a potential liquidity trap we have
any number of other symptoms of a
declining Empire and shouldn't the
question be not how do we get back where
we were but how do we
manage the decline and what would that
look like look you look pregnant with a
man I think that's an interesting
question I think the long run question
of how to manage decline and what with
all the overtones of national security
and cyber attacks and what else trade
flows and so on is a really big one but
I think I really and I think it's one
that deserves a long and detailed
discussion probably not with this group
or a lot only with this group but I
think the issue I would really like to
focus on are these two issues of the
fact we have these millions of people
unemployed and that is not because of
American decline that's because of
something some fiscal from monetary and
housing shocks and so on and how we're
going to get how we're going to get
those people back to work and also how
we're going to do it in a way that that
reduces the reverses that growing
inequality I see those as in a way
statistician say orthogonal to the
decline issue the decline issue has to
do with a whole number of things happen
to do with our interventions abroad the
monetary system and so on but but
managing I think any of the proposals
hear about getting us back to full
employment actually would not really
have a big effect one way or the other
on managing long-run decline yeah the
big problem we're facing is the rising
income inequality and the some of the
most important things we can do now are
to manage that somehow some things we've
done in the past have been constructive
we created in this country the Earned
Income Tax Credit which gives very low
income people a credit on their taxes
which helps them manage this difficult
situation a former Yale professor Ned
Phelps wrote a book called rewarding
work in which he argued that we should
give more subsidy to low-income low-wage
people the Income Tax Credit does that
but it does that only two
a subset married with children that and
it actually lowers the wages of has the
effect he argued of lowering the wages
of people who weren't in that category
so I think that this is a this answers a
lot of the issues that the Occupy Wall
Street people have that we're neglecting
the bottom element of this country and
we can do things it's better than
welfare a job subsidy that gets these
people hired thanks yes let's assume for
a moment that we have a massive
infrastructure investments and we have
these great roads and railroads and
people can move around and get wherever
they need to go what jobs are they going
to do when they get there in other words
what's the engine of economic growth if
we are able to come out of the the
short-term problem over the longer run
mother's run good i mean the problem the
fundamental problem we have John was
talking about a legacy of the crisis
which stays with us in the form of on
the balance sheets that are all which
but beyond that there's a problem of
loss of confidence and if you look at
the confidence index is there at
near-record low so for example the
University of Michigan has a question
that they asked about whether you think
there will be widespread unemployment or
depression for the next five years and
that's at the lowest it's ever been so
people think that there's something bad
happening and that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy so that's what
now the idea is that these things we
tend to get our confidence back we
realize this is a great country and that
we there will be new innovations and new
products but it takes time and part of
the motivation for a Keynesian stimulus
is to help accelerate that but past
depressions in the United States the
depression of the 1830s the depression
of the 1870s the depression of the 1890s
all resolve themselves without any
fiscal stimulus policy and so we're only
talking about i think this crisis will
come to an end we've been maybe to
negative here our confidence will come
back and American ingenuity will produce
new products and we'll have demand for
them oh but those recessions that you
cite all the way that we work naku from
all started with the ratio for example
of private debt to GDP far far lower and
public debt to GDP far far lower than
we started this one we'd never been
above two hundred and fifty percent of
GDP and we started this one at three
hundred and sixty percent of GDP rich
some of private all private Arabic and
and the public debt by the way was a
little teeny piece of this most there
was three hundred percent private debt
to GDP um it's hard it's you don't work
out as easily with that much overhang of
debt I would also add I mean I think
it's you can't really deny the the long
run you know there are long run issues
having to do with the mix of jobs that
the economy is producing has changed
right so there's there's the issue of
the economy's not producing enough jobs
there's also you know a sort of secular
change in the mix of jobs that the
economy is producing that returns to
education basically risen for the last
40 years and you know there are I mean I
think there are dislocation issues that
come from a mismatch between you know
temporary mismatches between this the
characteristics of the workers and the
characteristics of the jobs and that's
in many ways I think a separate problem
from the you know from the fiscal you
know the sort of short run problem that
the fiscal stimulus could could address
I think this is a very interesting
question and one that very troubling to
many people and it's the thing that the
point Judi just raised in the issue when
we get off the train and we build all
these things are there going to be any
jobs there this is something that has
been troubled Europeans quite a bit i
mentioned earlier the work sharing idea
that some other they're just not enough
they're just not enough jobs isn't
people we're not going to know what to
produce this comes up every deep
recession and every deep depression that
people say that we would we just are not
going to have enough to do i think the
lessons are there are lots of things
there are lots of things to do in the
lots of things that people want and if
you look at the job markets actually
until until the last
year two there was not a really well
there was not a growing mismatch between
job vacancies and and across industries
and job opportunities it looked as if
the there always is mismatched but it
looked as if it wasn't growing over time
it looked as if the slow of matching up
of workers and jobs was was continuing
as it usually does I I mean my own sense
is there are lots and lots of things
that this economy if the demand were
there there are lots of things that
people want their lots of things that
lots of not just state not just local
not just federal private as well
education lots of that people still want
houses lots of things so i don't i don't
see that there's either a lack of job or
a really serious mismatch i just see
it's really a lack of demand at the
present time i'm going to bother to
mention the recessions and depressions
other than the great depression and i
think great depression is a good lesson
for for what may happen follow this
great recession and lose there is one
view among the economist that argue that
the FDR in fact prolonged at the great
depression and the economy would have
probably snapped out in 1933 but instead
we had essential educate lost of lost
growth until 1939 and you know we've
seen all of the similar things you know
huge investment infrastructure was in
the all kinds of policies which at that
time were completely new and I'm just
afraid that this Great Recession is
going to generate again such a massive
change in the involvement of the
government and the economy that we're
going to be belong below trend for for
the next ten years it's not the
depression policy of keeping wages up
that's that's not happening that's what
I think you're referring to OHANA and so
chanukah Linehan is one example one can
think about many things in John talked
here about the financial factors and I
just honestly don't see that much
evidence that the financial factors
could just that marshal an impact on the
I think about all the financial
frictions people talk about now even at
the height of the of the crisis the
firm's could have financed ninety
percent of the firm's could have
financed their investment just out of
retained earnings and if they don't pay
the dividends and it's just not there I
don't think it's in the data I think at
just one thing more thing on the great
depression because it really was
different from the earlier ones and the
frightening thing about the great
depression is what got us out was a
fiscal stimulus of about thirty percent
of GDP in the form of World War two and
until that came along basically we there
was no sign at all until the rearmament
of 1940 that we were getting out of the
risk of the Great Depression so that's a
kind of frightening thought of you it's
even more than the Chinese stimulus but
only happened once what that great
diversity that Great Depression only
happened once yes you know I think I'm
mindful of the time and so I relative
some questioners lined up but why don't
we just take one more from each side and
the breath the rest of you want to ask
us questions after you may so I'd like
to focus on a looming global issue how
do you see a potential Greek or Italian
default affecting the US economy and job
market good question greet the fall yeah
income on the Greek the Greek on our
panel will bring American our panel
answer the question co-authors heracles
provide I guess a spoon of popping trees
chief economic advisors and I said at
the beginning of the crisis what's going
to happen in Greece said we are too
small to fail so so I still think that's
true that it's it's it's related to the
writing down principle on houses I had
to give the graduation speech at the
University of Athens Business and
Economics school this last June and I
told them that you know that more people
are going to be thrown out of their
houses for defaulting on American
mortgages than there are people in all
of Greeks and that the only way to deal
with the American problem is to write
down the principal and the only way to
deal with the Greek problem was to
perjure minee at all to forgive part of
their debt by the end of this plan
they're going to be 0 two hundred
percent of GDP they're the devil be
twice as big as their annual what was
their annual gdp there's there's not
you'll never be able to pay that off and
it's crazy to expect them to so
eventually i believe the debt will be
written down because it's not that big a
number and it might quell the spreading
crisis in new york so that's actually
what i expect to happen it's true that
in America if you look at the
correlation between stocks so if you're
running a hedge fund trying to pair off
stock trades for example the correlation
between stocks is vastly higher now
double for almost what it now what it
has been you know what it was a few
years ago so what that means is that all
the stocks are we acting together to
global lose everything if it goes up
together goes down together you don't
have one
doing and so much of that comes from the
worry about what's going to happen in
Europe and whether it's going to start a
huge monetary crisis so i think that the
Europeans have to restructure the debt
and they're gonna have to face up to
taking some losses I think the Greek
thing is easy to handle because it's so
small and just as Herot we said and if
they don't restructure their debt and
they keep kicking the can down the road
and figuring well maybe later it will
get solved then actually I think it does
you know our markets obviously react to
us it will be bad sure I just don't i
wanna i want to make a happy note here
if we think the u.s. is dysfunctional
and let's look at the euro land where
slovakia can bring down the union i mean
at least we're not in the situation
where one deviant state around the
nation can vote to not to have a bill go
forward so it could be worse last
question i had sort of an industry
specific question and i think it
piggybacks well on the conversation
about infrastructure I think
construction real estate architecture
have been some of the area's most hurt
by the recession and have also been the
slowest to recover I think construction
unemployment is more than double the
national nine percent in architecture i
believe is dropped thirty percent from
the pre-recession bubble and i just
wanted to hear your thoughts on the
future of these industries and how they
relate to the bigger picture just the
facts construction unemployment peaked
at twenty-seven percent in 2009 but it
has come back somewhat so it's no longer
double the overall unemployment rates
about last month was 13 and a half
percent still way too high but not it's
not it there has been some some recovery
in that sector any comments about the
substance there i'll just say one good
thing about housing well there's a
tremendous shortage of housing building
because the hardly bohemian houses built
in lines
years so if you were just looking dem
and plus there are a lot of young people
are coming of house only age so if you
just look demographically at what should
be happening now we should be starting
another housing boom so many people
actually have predicted that the whole
thing's over but the trouble is that the
housing prices are still being held so
low because all the speculators and
builders they understand that the
relatives of people going to be thrown
out of their houses and all these old
houses put on the markets although the
housing prices can't go up and so
there's no incentive to build new houses
but all the elements are there for a
renaissance in our you know a tremendous
resurgence in housing construction
because we actually we have a shortage
of housing not an in terms of recently
built houses and we've hardly ever had
so few houses built over a four-year
period it's it's really dramatic yeah
you are a little bit enthusiastic well I
do collection of surveyed on attitudes
toward housing with chip case and we
found that general optimism about the
housing market has been steadily
declining but in 2005 and there's
there's some we went through a major
cycle it was the biggest housing boom
boom in US history between 1997 and run
2006 and it's been going down for a long
time now I remind you what happened in
Japan they had a housing boom and a
stock market boom in the 1980s the
housing market peaked in 1991 and then
it declined for 15 consecutive years
lost two-thirds of its value then it
picked up in 2006 and people thought
this is the boom coming back right but
then it started going down an account so
it's not obvious that we're these
housing booms are historically very rare
on such a national scale very rare
phenomenon and it sounds plausible to me
that we're not going to I'm not saying
for sure but we're not going to get out
of this one
and we shouldn't have the idea that the
next boom is right around the corner
well maybe didn't say that this is a
legitimate difference about how
effective a writedown of underwater
mortgages would be you know I think
that's the you're certainly right that
the court is so you know we never had a
bone as big as this this one is a rare
it like the IC so compression was a very
good I she's over four years because not
be enough assume it's going to happen
yeah do a full renovation modernize it
beautifies a new
and then based upon the energy
conservation savings you can often pay
for most of it or cash flow and all
these finances loan from death so I
think that might be one of the markets
that these things are available and the
government you know it's a chain my
father doesn't really focus on it at all
having done a lot of renovation is
filled with energy retrofitting you're
there's certain things you're definitely
right about I mean window putting in new
windows that are energy efficient as a
very very positive payback definitely
pays off some things are less or more
more problematic and if you get into I
will also tell you from vieilles
experience comprehensive renovations of
buildings I wish they did pay for
themselves they don't but but but
specific targeted energy-saving
renovations many of them due to very
good point i just i don't i don't want
to I don't want to disagree but I just
do want to remind ourselves that the
construction industry is a pretty small
part of the overall economy and even
though it's extremely depressed even if
it were to bounce back fifty percent of
the way it sits down over fifty percent
in terms of the total construction
expenditures even if it were bounced
back it that would be only a small
fraction of what we need and if you
think of it that makes sense because if
a construction is only three percent of
the economy then you've got ninety-seven
percent that lots of other places where
there are workers who are unemployed and
there and there are jobs that are
unfilled so it's I think we can make it
we can make some movement in the
construction area but that's not going
to solve a very much of our overall
problem well if we're really putting
monies and unemployed construction
workers some of us would argue at least
from intuition that the multipliers more
than one okay okay so you get a little
bit of Bank I think it's been a great
discussion I want to thank the panel
sainthood very good daughter
you